je vais pas l'enfer des tranchées
racontée par un violoncelle en 1914 le
célèbre violoncelliste maurice maréchal
est mobilisée comme brancardier
il amène avec lui son instrument pour
apporter un peu de musique au front mais
évidemment violoncelle n'a pas la nappe
a la larme n'a pas les armes n'a pas le
napalm la conscience de l'homme il a un
certain recul vis-à-vis de ce qui s'y
passe donc c'est comme un enfant et donc
il ya de l'innocence et forcément il ya
de l'espoir
une histoire vraie racontée par hervé
mais seront dans une nouvelle en 2014
pour la pièce les musiciens ont leur
place sur scène en accompagnement du
texte on est un peu là comme des acteurs
pad pas des acteurs au même titre que
que le comédien qui joue le rôle du
violoncelle mais et on a une pas on est
vraiment intégré dans le dans les
spectacles comme la lumière d'ailleurs
fait aussi partie de ce spectacle
c'est ce violoncelle poilus qui raconte
sa grande guerre et sa relation avec son
musicien c'est comme un comédien dans
une compagnie en vie des histoires avec
les autres parfums sont délaissés on se
dit mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
m'emmènent là bas moi je voudrais aller
là bas et les histoires de jalousie dans
les compagnies tout ça j'ai considéré de
violoncelle comme ammann artistes avec
tout ce que ça implique
on abandonne par piocelle dans un autre
le spectacle s'adapte à toute la famille
pour une histoire de la grande guerre
d'un point de vue original